Well, I hope your keyboard didn't melt. When I ran it, got an error message.
Let me show you. The class compiled with no syntax erros. So I clearly don't
have a compile time error. But when I run the program, down here, I get an
error message. And Bluej tells me that something very bad happened in the
highlighted line. First off, it is a run time error. It's an error that
happened at run time. And it is so bad that it terminated my program and
displayed what's called an exception report. And the report is that a division
by zero was attempted. And that's of course very, very bad. you've seen how to
deal with a number of different kinds of errors, and you'll get to practice
that with Sarah right now.